what's really going on with Kanye West
we are drugged out we are controlled by
the media Elin puts the question to Kris
Jenner on her show today after the
rapper revealed a 2016 opioid addiction
and made controversial remarks about
slavery on TMZ live I know that he will
explain himself in his own way and I
think that anything he does and I just
think this is important to say is he
always does things with really good
intentions
meanwhile Kris fought back tears
praising Khloe's resilience in the wake
of the cheating scandal involving the
father of her baby girl Tristan Thompson
Khloe is amazing I'm so proud of that
kid honestly it makes me it gets so
emotional because I was just like it was
in Cleveland last week and it was
snowing and she was all nestled in and
the nursery but Kim she was pretty blunt
about the scandal Monday on Ellen I
don't even know how to describe it
besides it's just so a source tells et
Chloe remains in Cleveland and is
planning to fly back to LA with true for
Mother's Day we've also learned the 33
year-old is starting to work on her
revenge body
she's eating healthy and expects to get
official clearance to work out again in
the next few weeks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]